we're happy to see you all
and welcome to army first logic so what
we'll do today is we'll kind of briefly
talk about this upcoming program
and explain how you can use various
resources that we've prepared for you to
learn about biomedical data analysis
machine learning as well as some coding
in r and python
so first of all
why machine learning why data science so
as you probably know some of the highest
paying jobs and interesting tasks are
being prepared to tackle uh data in a
variety of ways and especially this is
happening in the world of biomedical
discovery pharmaceutical biotechnology
companies and the major objective for
these companies is to take biological
insights and translate them into
applications
and a lot of times to look deeper just
like we look in the microscope to
understand the details of a biological
sample today we turn to computational
analysis because the data is becoming
more and more complex large variable and
essentially
knowing how to use some of these tools
can be a major component of your job
description or it could be something
that just drives your career and it
allows you to explore data sets and gain
meaningful biological as well as
clinical insights so we'll talk a little
bit more about the types of applications
in a little bit
so what we want to do in this program is
really focus on some of the applications
of data science as well as machine
learning to different types of data
these data sets could describe
challenges in diagnostics when we talk
about clinical applications they could
be discovery of targets that could be
applicable to biotechnology or
pharmaceutical companies it could also
be for basic research where we look at
environmental samples clinical samples
animal models of human disease and try
to understand what is the data telling
us about a particular condition
phenotype
or biological process now i think the
most exciting thing is that there are
huge amounts of data available for
anyone to learn from and analyze on
repositories like the national center
for biotechnology information or ncbi
where you have layers of information
from processed information that has
already been analyzed and interpreted
and put into
review articles or
publications but including all the way
down to the raw data and especially for
the raw data
recently there has been an analysis in
2021
where over 15 petabytes of sra data
which is raw data raw sequencing rates
that have been deposited on ncbi so what
is 15 petabytes 15 petabytes is 15 000
terabytes of raw data raw sequence
archives
now that includes some process data as
well there's over 100 000 public data
sets for geo which is gene expression
omnibus transcriptomic data
and there are a lot of over six million
genbank sequences which means over six
million uh individual
species that have been sequenced and
their genomes have been assembled now a
lot of this is driven
by what's happening right now what are
the hot topics in research including
clinical research including basic
research and one of the major drivers i
think right now
is the pandemic which has brought about
almost real-time sequencing uh to the
forefront really allowing many of us to
not only learn about the impact of the
pandemic but also look at how we can
contribute to the understanding of this
pandemic
now when it comes to such a diverse
series of data we need to understand
what are the properties and challenges
associated with each one
onyx data is a variety of comprehensive
views of a particular type of data now a
lot of times this is generated using
what's called high throughput
technologies these technologies include
phenomics genomics epigenomics and
transcriptomics and all of these
are relying on high throughput or
automated technologies to generate huge
collections of data sets now because
they are so variable and they speak
about different molecular properties you
have to rely on computational
technologies to be able to
learn from these data sets analyze these
data sets explore these data sets and
make use of these data sets and these
computational technologies are basically
rooted in data science and so in this
program that we're going to introduce
you today to we're going to focus on
some of these data science skills that
you need to have to be able to
efficiently process analyze and
visualize such complex biomedical data
so what are some of the things that we
are going to cover in this program first
of all we're going to talk about
analytical methods uh how to visualize
and analyze the data complexity and
reduce it so that we can extract
meaningful insights we'll introduce you
to the terminology for machine learning
and artificial intelligence and
biomedical discovery so that when you
read the paper and you hear about a
method
you know what it does and you know what
it means we'll also provide you with
some project examples so you'll see how
other people have used machine learning
now machine learning is used in many
different ways and so you'll see how
it's not just
clustering or classification you'll see
how different types of machine learning
methods are actually used in a variety
of tasks related to the whole process
from
getting raw data to then making it
useful for analysis or structuring it
cleaning it preparing it for
analysis and then finally turning it
into a model or learning from it
essentially
using the complex patterns in that data
now as a result what we expect the
participant to gain out of this program
is to really have an understanding of
how machine learning algorithms are used
in analysis of almonds data you'll
understand the differences between
different types of machine learning
models and different types of problems
that they can be applied to you'll also
see practical examples so you'll have a
sense of how other experts have used
this and what are the specific
challenges that they had to address to
make their project work and we will
introduce you to some of the popular and
user-friendly python and our packages so
that you gain
practical skills you can actually use
these skills to code yourself and you
will be able to read other people's code
understanding what packages are being
used and how to use them yourselves and
so these are going to include some
examples that we'll actually do today in
this session so that you get a sense of
how can you get all of this done in a
short period of time
so the data science program the
omnilogic data science program
is really structured around these four
different things understanding the
various omics data types learning to
explore them
then to try big data analysis in the
context of a project and then to
understand the link between data and
biology how do you actually master
biological interpretation leveraging
some of these tools so let's talk a
little bit about the syllabus so the
syllabus of this program is organized
into three different parts introduction
methods
an in-depth review of methods
and finally the project section so all
together we'll have three different
sections the first one is then we'll
introduce you to the relevant
terminology and key concepts to refresh
your memory and get you started so that
you're well oriented in this whole field
of omics and machine learning
the second one we'll talk about methods
that will give you a practical sense of
commonly used methods and functions for
analysis of our mixed data starting from
exploration to statistical testing to
supervising and supervised machine
learning as well as deep learning and
then finally some project examples so
that you have a sense of applications
for such methods and
after you complete the full program we
hope that you will have the confidence
to understand and analyze data that you
can conduct independently to a data set
of your choice and we'll also introduce
you by the way to some examples at the
end so you
can kind of try it out before you do
your own independent work
so the program itself is going to
combine interactive sessions just like
we're having today
in each session you will find additional
links to asynchronous resources that
review and enrich the covered topics so
it's the live sessions plus the
self-guided study materials that you can
practice and go deeper into if you want
to learn more about the technical the
theoretical or the application of the
particular topic
and as we kind of talk about a lot of
topics in general i want to kind of give
you a high level overview of each one of
these topics
so a lot of what we are talking about
when we say words like transcriptomics
genomics or metagenomics might be
confusing to some of you and so we will
start in the beginning to kind of
explain what is the link between
omics data
the biological
features the molecular features that
they describe and how can the data that
comes from a an automated process like
sequencing can be used to essentially
prepare it for analysis so we want to
link together the biological the
technical and the data components
together to kind of make sense of the
important terminology and give you a
practical sense of what does this data
look like and how does it work in terms
of using it for data analysis
then in the second part
in the second part we'll talk about the
machine learning topics unsupervised and
supervised learning how are these
methods used for various tasks such as
visualization organization of data
finding signal in noisy omix data as
well as things like predictive analysis
and feature selection so to use these
methods you will need to understand how
they work what are the inputs what are
the variables what are the different
settings and available packages that
combine multiple functions that make the
methods that we described easy to deploy
right so you can understand the method
in detail but then as you want to deploy
it you want some user-friendly or some
kind of a short cut to essentially
launch and train that model so that's
what you will learn in this second part
you will learn to load data select a
method and run it to get an output that
you can interpret for that particular
model
using these principles we will then
review additional methods that are
useful for biomedical discovery that
include network analysis such as pathway
analysis for biologists generalized
linear models that are used to
distinguish between expression profiles
of transcripts for example and complex
transfer atomic data as well as deep
learning models that can be used for
specific types of situations to improve
accuracy and decrease feature
engineering which is a lot of what
conventional machine learning relies on
and then we'll also talk about the need
to combine various machine learning
models into a series of steps to achieve
more complex tasks for example when we
talk about single cell data
and finally we will talk about specific
use cases that can show you how the
methods we reviewed have been used by
researchers to find meaningful insights
in complex experiments biological
samples animal models or patient data
and so with the few examples we review
as case studies you can also then
develop a project of your own
to fi or follow our asynchronous
tutorials to reproduce an analysis that
you can improve upon turning it into a
novel study so what are some of these
projects
we'll talk about cancer macrophages
which is an important part of the immune
system and the immune response to tumor
growth we'll talk about different types
of pandemics like enterovirus malaria or
ebola virus we'll talk about modeling
cancer precision medicine where we can
find biomarkers and learn how different
patients respond to different treatments
we'll talk about tumor micro environment
but we'll also introduce projects that
are not clinical in essence things like
drought resistance or different stresses
that are important for crop production
and environmental preservation
so as a result i think that you will
really get a full overview of the data
science kind of a
process in biomedical research
to understand how different stages of
analysis work together to help define
the hypothesis as well as prepare the
data for meaningful application of
machine learning for big data practical
challenges so as a result you'll be able
to take a data set make it useful and
then explore it from a biological
perspective to understand really what
does it mean
as a result of completing all of these
different steps you will also get a
certificate so as already mentioned by
somalica you will get the certificate
after completing all of these different
steps on the omixler portal
so now to kind of explain how all of
these different resources are linked
together and how to use them i want to
give you a practical sense of how this
works so for those of you that have not
signed up yet
please go on to learn
onyxlogic.com
and sign up and create an account and
then i will show you a couple of just
really simple practical examples to
illustrate what we will do so this is
the page where you have registered
on the learn portal for this webinar and
as you can see it explains everything
that i've described today
and right here on the top if you already
have an account we can go to the courses
page
and what i will do is i will take one
example from the asynchronous materials
that we will go through to just kind of
illustrate what will be going on so if
you go into the search tab right here on
the course page if you go into the
search go to data science
and you will see here
bioml in python and bioml in r
as well as some additional resources
that you can look at but right now we'll
just take one example from this
introduction to data science in r
and let's take a look at some of the
basic tasks that you have
to get started with as you are
considering this program
so this is uh the course i'm just going
to paste the link again in chat for
those of you that want to follow along
and in this course this is again r
coding course two introduction to data
science with bioml you will see all of
the different
courses that we have there's about 10
courses here that go from very very
basic things or how to load data and
check for variable data all the way to
advanced supervised machine learning
right so let's take a look i'm going to
use
this
course right here or this lesson right
here anyone without a paid subscription
can access this lesson it's called data
processing and visualization
and basically what it talks about is
once you have a table once you have a
table of gene expression a table of otu
taxonomy in metagenomic sequencing of
the microbiome or whether you have some
kind of frequency of mutations across
the genome of a virus you will have a
table in this table you will have
different types of data this data can
include
continuous numeric data such as
transcriptomic gene expression it could
have names of samples and names of genes
or otus and it can also have categories
so these could be groups of samples that
maybe define a particular type of
samples that you have
now to analyze such data you can explore
different methods of visualization that
summarize the data in a meaningful way
and that can include
crosstabs or pivot tables they can
include box plots that summarize
statistical properties of each sample or
each group and they can include
continuous data
like scatter plots that allow us to find
relationships and organization of data
that could be potentially
interesting from a signal standpoint so
as we go through this introduction
you'll kind of learn about some of these
methods and then we can jump into the
breakdown of this code now what's
important
is first of all loading the data and so
here you have an example of how you load
a data set
that is already on github
well this particular example is on our
portal but we'll also be introducing you
to how to use github to kind of manage
and organize your code as well as data
sets then you can pre-process and
transform your data for analysis
so here you can see that we can for
example prepare the data matrix from the
data frame that we have to create some
numeric data for analysis
then you can also
load a library a library is just a
compilation of different functions that
are going to be useful for the analysis
and streamline your analysis and in that
data you now have an option to create a
visualization like a box plot right so
after we learn
about how this code is organized and
what are the different elements of this
code we can actually go in to practice
it yourself right here in the browser so
let's go into practice it yourself
and let's try over here
to run this analysis so you see that now
you have a console
you click on run
and after this step is complete you have
a message success running code and
essentially you get an output that was
predefined for you to make sure that
you're following the steps now here
nothing really has to change it's
already made for you what you can do
though is you can check what's in this
data so let's go in here and we'll edit
it and we will put in head
df which is the name of our data frame
to understand what is in our data so
after we have calculated the mean which
is right here we now see what is in our
data now this is a little bit difficult
to understand as you can see there's a
lot of different columns there's a lot
of different numbers it's not very clear
what do they actually mean
a more useful way to look at this data
is to actually visualize it what's in it
and so here we have a scatterpod plot
boxplot histogram and heatmap but all of
it is connected into one single piece of
code and as a result we might be a
little bit confused as to what exactly
are we looking at so let's modify this a
little bit here we also have descriptive
statistics converted into matrix draw a
box plot a heat map and a histogram so
let's start with the box point so we'll
just remove
this run it
and now we have a box block now what is
a box plot a box plot essentially shows
us
how the data for each sample that we
have on the x-axis can be summarized
using the interquartile range
maximum and minimum values outliers as
well as the median line for each one
this gives us a sense of what's in the
data that is fairly complex we have here
a bunch of samples and inside each
sample we have certain level of
variability that we should be using to
understand differences between what we
see right here which is the names of
groups or conditions that we're trying
to interpret now what's important about
this visualization is that it should
immediately give us a sense of how ready
is this data for downstream analysis
right so if we want to analyze a
difference between normal like samples
and let's say basal or luminal breast
cancer subtypes we want to understand
that within each group there's some
consistency that we can rely on to make
sure that these samples accurately
represent the condition that we're
studying
and that is really what this whole
course is about this course is going to
go into the detail of the code but also
link it with the biological question
that you're trying to ask to really
understand
what is the process of going from raw
data to an answer to a question that is
either biological in nature clinical in
nature or has some intro interpretable
uh insights for somebody working in
industry like biotechnology or
pharmaceutical
so with this i want to really make sure
that it's clear
that in the context of the program we
will cover a lot of topics in sessions
like we did today going through code and
running examples
at the end you will be able to download
all of this code you can copy it and we
will use what's called google colab to
make sure that all of the code that you
work on is not only tested automatically
in on our platform but also is reviewed
by someone so that at the end you come
out with a whole series of
full code from beginning loading
exploration finally to training a
machine learning model and then
interpreting your results and all of
that by the way is going to be
integrated on your own profile so at the
end
when you share your outcome you will see
all of the different projects and all
the different courses that you have
completed you will also have the option
to develop an independent project so
here after you have a certain number of
points after you've completed the
minimum requirements you will be able to
apply this to a data set of your own
essentially turning it into a mini
publication that starts from
submitting this project right here on
this learn portal that will guide you
through all the different steps that you
need to take and then you can actually
use this to maybe go for a poster
presentation or a full publication if
you have a meaningful project
so with that i want to make sure that i
answer any questions that you might have